I know 30 seconds of logos isn't
terribly long but there are so many of
these curse packed in that I can't help
but sin it I'm not sure what looks more
fake the Oasis or this / CGI'd Shack
stack ma'am I haven't seen product
placement this obvious in a movie since
some asshole heavily featured Reese's
Pieces in some movie I can't remember I
don't doubt that the Oasis gives you a
chance to be a pole dancer if you like
or whatever this is I just doubt many
people engaging in this activity would
leave their curtains open I was born in
2027 after giving us a pretty fun
unbroken shot movie serves up a heaping
helping of narration can climb Mount
Everest with Batman yeah but I would
want to climb Mount Everest as Batman it
wants to climb a mountain with Batman
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
also them I guess for the other choices
of climbing partner are Bugs Bunny Harry
Potter neo Godzilla Richard Kimble in
addition to other WB stars check out
this place it's a casino the size of a
planet and if there's a section of the
movie set there that involves a brief
incarceration a random meeting with a
morally ambiguous code breaker and an
animal escape you can expect a fan
revolt okay so here's a line to go
through some portal but they're in a
virtual world so why is there a line at
all I can see that there are multiple
portals but why aren't there more
stacked and an so that lions are no
longer I think I know this is a
simulation you know but what the but
Freddy Krueger be doing on a planet full
of people blasting giant scorpions and
Freddy's out of his depth on this planet
and he's not even in a dream
Jerry is one if wait is reading the
description of the artifact why didn't
he read it like it's actually written he
really needed to convert the time units
for the sake of exposition all your
money um how is this guy playing the
game sitting at a restaurant everyone
we've seen so far has been standing up
running and jumping around their real
space but this dude can just sit when he
plays this would be an orgy of evidence
that this is a little girl's room except
for the fact that I don't think it's an
orgy of evidence that it's this little
girl's room she putting on a front for
her parents
yeah like Donkey Kong jr. plush toys and
a plethora girly but what I really like
to do is pull noobs on Planet doom the
most dangerous place in the Oasis and
okay look there's Jason another guy who
shouldn't be too tough to kill on this
planet they should have called Planet
doom Warner Brothers Park apparently
this company allows their employees to
go to the Oasis while on the clock don't
ask me how this dude was playing at his
desk and not causing a scene before he
died and that's what he gets for playing
as Jason Voorhees if you want to reach
under your seats you'll find that
there's nothing there dick if you're
watching this I'm dead if you're
watching this I'm dead cliche I create
into three hidden keys to three magic
games damn holidays character when from
Garth Algar to Geoffrey Rush in seconds
flat no one has even gotten one key some
long-forgotten Gunter cracked the first
clue and found the first challenge
though I spent time telling you how that
guy act the first clue when we can take
you straight to the first challenge
filled with even more pop-culture
references I mean what fun is it to use
your brain to solve puzzles and be an
active participant when watching a movie
zero thought I said also the first guy I
didn't get any points for finding the
first portal well toughing gaining the
only ones still trying are the Gunter's
as in egg hunters oh and of course the
Sixers that's because you gotta trust
the process and just following the
orders at the head of I oh I this
dickweed named Nolan Sorento this is
where the story has an immediate flaw in
my eyes while I truly believe evil
corporations would be doing something
like this the real antagonist should be
the scavenger hunt itself Wade versus
everybody else adding an evil villain
into this mix takes away from the funk
also at this point I think Ben
Mendelsohn's played a bad guy in a
big-budget movie as many times as Bruce
Greenwoods been the president I've got a
question about this DeLorean
aside from the obvious look at that it's
the DeLorean way it makes an appearance
when you're in the Oasis does every car
have the same speed capabilities are
they confined to the vehicles real-world
capabilities if so a DeLorean can only
go from zero to 60 in roughly eight
seconds and at a top speed of 110 miles
an hour which I imagine sucks in a race
like this the last time we saw these
assholes a few seconds ago Artemis was
way the hell ahead of weight but now
they're neck and neck girl I think it's
Artemis so during this crazy-ass race
with killer obstacles I figured I'd give
you more exposition about her rather
than waiting until it's over watching
this race I guess thank God that nobody
other than a select group of believers
still try to do this can you imagine
sticking another thousand or so people
in this thing also this whole race seems
to be against the spirit of what holiday
represents why would you need to enter
this race at scheduled times against
tons of opponents it's a virtual world
so why can't you just do this any time
you want against the AI and if you
manage to win the race then you open the
door for others to copy you and get past
the first challenge by doing no work
whatsoever
if Possible's DeLorean has the no roads
option why the hell isn't he flying all
over this hey guys on Last Action Hero
reference for the wimp
this ten-second t-rex scene is somehow
better than both Jurassic world and its
sequel
[Music]
it Kong seriously just peace out after
destroying the road you can see them
right here right what if they found
another way around Wade's car isn't even
damaged sad to say this is the most
successful movie that the Iron Giant has
ever been in favorite restaurant was
Chuckie Cheese I know holiday was a nerd
but no person on this earth would put
Chuckie Cheese down as their favorite
restaurant outside of someone who was
five I stopped because of Kong no one
ever makes it past Kong that's like a
rule if possible knows this then why was
he so confident when he got close to the
finish line
he knew Kong was hot on this trip I need
every edge I can get every push punch
gunshot you feel it all
how does feeling pushes punches and
gunshots give you an edge and from what
we've seen gunshots just kill you
immediately so what good is that Jesus
how many retro bags of Doritos does this
family need one on the fridge one on the
coffee table wait this is the virtual
reality or is it reality reality because
if it's the latter Wade's a superhuman
who can take a direct punch to the face
without any physical damage to him or
his glasses how will you eat up my
valuable such time today isn't providing
information to Gunter's the curators
only job and it's not like there's
anybody else here so why isn't he
ecstatic the parcel is here to use it
some things you're perfect just the way
they are asteroids people don't live
inside an asteroids arcade cabinet the
scene is a perfect example of how easy
it is for British actors to do a
believable American accent and because
that's not fair I'm sending these all
right Micah gates I can't go backwards
for watch backwards really fast fast as
we can this is the clue it's one of the
most forward over pieces of video in the
holiday journals and yet nobody figured
it out for five years remember a whole
bunch of assholes have tried that race
over and over knowing King Kong is
impossible to get past and yet nobody
thought this go backwards thing was
important also it's AI Butler guy was
told we're finished but kept playing the
video long after and yeah I know he's
actually simon Pegg's avatar but how
many times has he seen people not get
this clue there's nothing special about
wait lots yet anyway back again so soon
you know considering she's a well known
Gunther it's extremely weird that
parsable is never seen Artemis until the
last race and now she's apparently had
all of them Wow wait isn't nearly this
close to Artemis
oh come on newbie got the DeLorean the
triumphant moment you've even got Alan
and Sylvester doing your school you
can't put in some actual Back to the
Future music I was just wondering what
that does the scoreboard matter if the
goal is to find the keys and solve
holiday scavenger hunt the points hardly
matter we estimate we can sell up to 80
percent of an individual's visual field
before inducing seizures does a company
need with eighty percent advertisements
if they win the contest and own the
Oasis which is worth half a goddamn
trillion dollars and is a money printing
machine
yeah greed and whatnot but you'd lose
probably half the people who go to the
Oasis hope that coca-cola revenue is
enough to make up for it also it's funny
how IO is considered an evil corporation
while Halliday and Mauro or considered
Saints even though everything in the
Oasis cost money and they set up a
system where it's difficult to compete
with richer players whoa smack you did
some Equis pull a Biff and go back in
time to steal the Rubik's Cube for this
design x1 have two possible shopping in
the Oasis so when you buy something that
can only be used in the Oasis like the
Holy Hand Grenade that makes sense but
you can buy something in the Oasis that
you can use in the real world right
there are drug dealers here that you can
pay and fake money and they make actual
deliveries because that's the movie I
want to see oh yeah orgasm boxing this
haphazard password storage is going to
be a huge plot point later but why does
he even need the password this
think-think scans his face when he sits
down discount Thanos there's only three
things in this world I hate steampunk
pirates and tabbouleh this character is
as unnecessary in this movie as TJ
Miller is unnecessary as a comedian he
totally totaled his car but then show
got it - how did he total his car the
track that you drive on has absolutely
no obstacles I'm not wearing that
Artemus just made a huge big deal about
parsable not being able to walk around
without a disguise but why is she not
wearing one anymore she was the second
player to get the key and she was a
previously famous blogger so why isn't
she getting mobbed - Halliday went on a
date with Ogden tomorrow's wife just
once years before they were even marry
how does she not know this isn't she
just as obsessed with these journals as
he is and she missed this the name Kiera
is only mentioned once in all of
holidays journals that's not possible
and the curator character is the most
annoying thing about this movie he's a
goddamn machine he's also ogden maro and
his sole purpose is to search the
archives
searching for one word that should take
less than off think second can you drink
things in the Oasis why are there empty
cans of coke and tab in this virtual den
and I see a hint of Pepsi you got two
huge competitors to share time in the
same movie how much did Coke pay to turn
that Pepsi around oh why it's not
changing your identity out in the alesis
a thing anymore like this movie blew its
wad on a Goro alien reference for
Artemus and gave him a Clark Kent
disguise and the motherfucker hasn't
used it's it's I mean even Artemus
didn't remind him to use it again and
this is gonna be a big deal for the plot
[Applause]
[Music]
wait does he have control over
everybody's experience at this dance
club like I'm grooving to fucking Daft
Punk and some asshole can change it to
the Bee Gees seriously no place you can
go in this virtual world that isn't safe
holiday actually built this dance hall
and he didn't put any rules about
shooting people here you always got to
be on guard did you know what I said I
set him in love with you tease man the
power of boners will make you forget
that you're getting shot at you could
lose all your I guess
Andy's ioi agents definitely studied
Star Wars especially the excellent
stormtrooper Reem they both survived
this Zemeckis cube turns everything back
in time 60 seconds I guess it's got the
same Marty McFly logic to where he
didn't give himself enough time to
change anything
also why doesn't the cube turn back time
for him anonymous do you really think
that anyone's gonna give a damn about an
explosion in some ghetto trash rat
Vaughn in Columbus our villain who I
will reiterate is the worst thing about
this story tells Wade there's an
explosion coming a full minute before it
explodes giving him ample time even if
he were in the trailer Sorrento thinks
he's in to get out before blows don't do
this I'm not even there I'm for long I
know he's all horned up for a murdering
but why wouldn't Sorento at least check
to see if Wade's telling the truth here
all he knows is that no one's seen Wade
for three days he doesn't think that's
the least bit suspicious I don't want to
hear your voice ever again oh no way
it's terrible and her asshole boyfriend
got blown up I wish I cared but this
explosion leaves me empty vaguely glad
it happened
wow this thing blew up in top of the
stacks in a perfect way so that Wade
would have to implement the teachings of
the Prometheus school of running away
from things I oh I came for me in the
real world are you kidding me this
enormous henchman was able to hide
behind this puny desk chair a real name
is Samantha but yeah I'm Artemis
I thought they'd set up way to be in
love with Artemis and he says I'd love
you even if you're hideous but then she
turned out to be ridiculously hot so he
never has to test that hypothesis I'm
living this close to each other at all
time yeah it's a pretty big enormous
coincidence right like I know
is the new hotness and all but the on to
the two most successful Gunter's living
within a couple miles of each other is
really stretching suspension of
disbelief absolutely that my whole life
you don't have to pretend this just
rings plain false I could understand her
not thinking she's attractive because of
the large birthmark but I do not believe
for one minute that people treat her all
that differently this is like the
mystique conundrum to me only it's
sillier and it's not like there's a ton
of birthmark fetishes out there who skew
the results a place where the leaf
wasn't taken where the date was at the
movies wait when did everybody decide
that they would be teaming up late and
Samantha did all this on their own but
then they just calling all the guys they
think are trustworthy at the drop of a
hat I don't the others do any research
with them the shining eyetality is 11th
favorite horror film Jesus Christ he
ranked his favorite movies by genre past
he's clearly wrong by the way and it's
based on the best-selling book by
Stephen King who hated the movie yeah
that doesn't mean he hated his creation
it means he hated Stanley Kubrick's
version of it that's a fudging of the
clue ma'am okay so now my next question
is how hasn't anyone stumbled across
this before and discovered a weird
playable version of The Shining yet I've
never seen The Shining it's a really
scary me moving H is a high level
Gunther and parsable said this movie is
one of Halliday's favorites so how the
hell has H not seen it did H just get
knocked around by The Shining Greatest
Hits how is he getting pulled out of the
freezer from the hedge maze what a bunch
of bull Stanley Kubrick will likely come
back to life after this and slap Steven
Spielberg around and then wait another
15 years to make a new movie Howdy's
greatest fear wasn't the shining or any
book or movie his biggest fear was
kissing a girl
that's the leap you couldn't take I like
how this is being shared as new
information when that's exactly why
they're here in the first place remember
this he had a chance with Keira his
chance to kiss her he didn't take delay
so let's stop wasting time already none
of this is in the shining the whole
shining trivia is just a diversion
rendering it utterly meaningless glad we
could take a stroll down memory lane to
watch some famous scenes of The Shining
when all somebody had to do is look in
the ballroom and find Kiera dancing I
mean seriously
outside of the figuring out the shining
clue what's hard about completing this
challenge Canada hands this is what the
task is asking her to dance but they've
been saying that the kiss was what was
important yet this is the first thing
Artemis tries probably because a lesbian
lip lock would have made a few squares
run out of the theater screaming one of
our ologist saw them enter the media
library she cracked the clue we just
have to win the shining challenge do any
of the good guys want to use the forum
Clark Kent glasses that change their
avatar
just fucking once so they can't follow
them around I mean goddamn mr. Sorrento
I really think you need to see this I
think you need to see this cliche now
possible it's called the Jade key yeah
but how are these other Sixers also in
the game now if parsable just now want
it's already been shown that everyone
else in the house is kicked outside the
movie theater once someone takes the
lead well ain't got one of those van
thingies I guess we'll stop at the
pursuit here even though we have very
useable guns probably a nearby vehicle
and tell those drones to stop droning
while you're not doing anything how did
I oh I find that their challenge so fast
I oh I cracked the first three lines the
clue and the person who isn't driving
answer this question keep your eyes on
the road for Christ's sake also we never
find out how the answer to the third
location is solved it's a solution
without proof forever and ever an Atari
2600 sir every game ever made for it
thousands of possibilities even Custer's
revenge also why didn't Halliday make it
possible for multiple players with two
keys to enter infinite duplicates of
this world to attempt the challenge why
is there a fucking line of people trying
games the way the challenges are set up
really short changes the possibilities
of this world and it's like they forgot
they can literally do anything and avoid
bottlenecks like this how are there no
Gunter's here already I know the high
five or otherwise engaged but the words
out on ioi finding the third clue and
it's taken a while to get this orb up
and running when is she wait please the
pronoun game which I am sure Halliday
was not a fan of so that Sorento has to
figure out who the hell she is
also these guys have hacked into
Sorrento's rig making him think that
he's in the real world including using
avatars that look exactly like the real
selves which reminds me again how many
times these dicks didn't use disguises
when they went egg honey Wow I thought
the security was last when Dido and
parsable did their sham break it but
there's literally no security outside
Sorrento's office door doesn't even lock
why can't every single one of these
avatars remain disguise during this
operation why does he even need to pull
off this disguise right now other than
to tell us Mission Impossible style
that's what he's doing and tip-off
Sorento later even if you don't think
your loyalty employees can see this
hatch because of the helmets they wear
why would you even install a hatch that
can be open from the inside don't worry
about the case sensitive nature of man
only ponder the capabilities and the
destructive power of man through the
course of time really this rig has that
kind of reflective surface wouldn't the
reflection from here just be the back of
the rig how is it perfectly capturing
all of his captors from here there was a
much cooler way to figure this out by
looking at
your eyes but let's just go with the
impossible reflection sure what's poppin
that sounds like a great inscription for
our tombstones
I guess Sorento would be excellent if
not a little overdramatic at cinemasins
sure samantha has the password but
didn't this rig scan Sorrento's face
earlier I guess it forgot some have lost
if free souls lost their lives damn
movie title ain't dead - in this version
so what's up with the hard for shadowing
also the books don't matter and now this
a force field around the 3rd challenge
I blame how it it why the would you make
it possible for someone to use a magical
item around the challenge at all this is
a world he created and easily could have
restricted use of any items that made
the unfair
Samantha has one goddamn job here and
then she can leave I'm sure this is a
captivating speech and all but she's got
the spell so get the fuck out of there
already
activate iron giant earlier we saw H on
planet doom trying to win an artifact
that turned her into a giant robot for 2
minutes but why did she even try to
enter that deathmatch when she was
building a fully functional iron giant
are you willing to zero out for the
Oasis are you willing to fight god damn
another young adult adaptation that
creates this awesome world ends up
distracted by revolution ready player
one could have been the tits y'all I
don't have time to explain how this ioi
extracts maximum fun from this movie but
it just does so is this movie saying any
asshole can strap into one of these
suits and just enter the oasis without a
password
I know these Sixers are supposedly
mindless worker bees but not even a one
two three four five password well I
watch this crazy battle unfold I'm
wondering what the fuck are they
shooting at there is no army coming at
them yet and there's no more shield and
the only thing they can do now is
destroy Halliday's fortress that
contains the third key so what's the
plan these two giant armies clash with
one another battles have actually become
boring over the years a whole buncha who
gives it and who the cares lost in an
Eyes Wide Shut orgy of CGI paint a
Twisted Sister and it's weird they're at
least two Pacific Rim sequels in the
same year I don't even understand how
this is possible
holiday actually allowed in his
simulation for you to stick charges into
the fridge and blow it up if this place
plays like the deathmatch arena it is
then the environment itself shouldn't be
damaged considering how much wear and
tear it would undergo every time a
deathmatch is played here also it's a
little weird that before this blue TJ
Miller's character didn't even phone in
a bomb threat I
could hit the iron Giants head with this
weapon and just kill it right now but
decides to go for the hands so that
eventually gravity will decide this Holy
Hand Grenade how much the bat cost less
and it's gonna cost some hey didn't
count to three
he lost not adventure this guy writes
off the correct game being adventurer
even though the clear rule for the
incorrect game is to be sunk into the
ice after playing less than one minute
do play an adventure Ferb I think it was
nine hours that's what it felt like
anyway so did I oh I play extra
terrestrials a game created by skill
screen back in 1983 or did they play the
infamous eet and this is Spielberg's way
of acknowledging it and distancing
himself from it by spelling it out and
making it plural it's pretty easy if you
know what you're doing really let me
finish it for you all the other keys
were solo projects we're only one person
at a time was allowed at the challenge
but on the last one where you can see
what the other person's doing Halliday
said should be fine to allow a bunch of
people to watch no one's gonna threaten
bodily harm to the other I'm actually
fine he has this extra life thing but he
did practically nothing to earn it he
got it from that curity guy earlier in
the movie all because he made a bet that
Kira was only mentioned once in the
entire archive I bet the book did
something different that was a lot more
satisfying but the books don't matter so
onward and upward a massive troll job
from Halliday here you actually have to
reach out and grab the key or else it
doesn't count your avatars can vacuum up
unlimited coins but a key is too goddamn
hard meanwhile doesn't this climactic
scene feel an awful lot like Inception
this is the moment that Halliday made
moral sign over his shares and
gregarious sure this is another test but
what happened if possible failed is he
out of the game does he still have all
three keys what do you have to go
through the whole process again even
though he knows how to beat the levels
I'm just saying this is a totally
unnecessary plot twist that doesn't have
any bearing on the quest itself this is
the button if you push it the whole
simulation shuts down that's why it's
easily accessible and can be pushed on
accident seriously this asshole Halliday
can't find the egg meanwhile Sorrento is
getting closer to knocking Wade out of
the Oasis while dickhead here looks for
it seriously if something happens to
Wade here isn't gregarious games and
breach of contract if they don't give
the company to him after doing
everything required by the game to win
you're not an avatar
are you no it's how are they really dead
yes then what are you the right person
oh something that would be way
unsatisfying to here explain so we'll
keep it unexplained we brought up a
mystery you didn't even need Wade off
tomorrow
yeah I'm pretty surprised too this
mother
or hasn't been in hardly any of this
movie so this is a slightly different
contract from the one Wade refused to
sign just a minute ago when he learned
he was being tested but it's still a
contract where the buyer buys the
company for a billion dollars it has
nothing to do with giving the company
over for winning the contest he's a
curator movie reveals Simon Pegg was the
curator all but does that mean he was in
the simulation every day attending to
every single person who ever walked
through therefore every waking minute
hope that was by appointment only the
third thing we did wasn't as popular we
closed the Oasis on Tuesdays and
Thursdays meaning people who only used
it Tuesdays and Thursdays because those
were their only days off from work we're
fucked why not just put a limit on the
amount of days in a week rather than
cutting out specific days and don't they
go to school using the Oasis oh my god
he just ran in you can do anything go
anywhere coffee in Paris surfed the
Maldives took a little nap on Mount
Kilimanjaro loyalty division is
reporting profits up 28% finale
we're opening five new loyalty centres
this month snotty bean meet twice last
night it was wonderful
even without it from your favorite movie
thank you
you're gonna wear the shirt of the band
you're gonna go see don't be that guy
[Music]
I heard the music and I pulled myself up
the stairs then I saw you dancing so you
found my jade key and one more thing
must find the Jade monkey before the
next full moon
[Applause]
sweet coins
[Music]
bawls language is hard I don't feel so
good